puis vous êtes rentré sur ce plateau le
chiot groulx je vois que vous avez un
avenir extrêmement grave c'est normal
avec tout ce qui s'est passé et je vous
vois regardez un peu ce débat enfin je
joue son jeu sont en a qui jouent sont
tristes je remarque que la raison se
mêle à l'émotion
les gens essaient de contenir un petit
peu ce qui reste de la raison dans une
charge émotionnelle intense quand même
notre pays a traversé des dix épreuves
douloureuses donc certainement il ya
l'émotion donc on pense également avec
les tripes
si nous sommes neuronale mais également
tripale donc nous sommes ainsi constitué
mais nous sommes dans le pays de
descartes
nous sommes dans le pays peut être le
plus rationnel de tous les systèmes de
philosophie politique la république le
pouvoir contre pouvoir conseil d'état
consacre aussi c'est notre pile et les
géniales à cet égard ce qui permet
d'ailleurs de réguler les débats ont
permanencière toujours l'émotion est
toujours une guerre civile froide en
permanence mais toujours régulée par
cette rationalité de la droite des
valeurs des valeurs de la république qui
sont toujours universel et qui vont
triompher
je pense que les preuves que nous
traversons va vont renforcer les valeurs
de la république malgré les apparences
c'est ce qu'il faudrait mais de ce qu'on
voit actuellement sur les réseaux
sociaux sur les plateaux que lui ce
qu'on voit dans les rues ce qu'on entend
on à l'impression au contraire qu' à une
escalade l'a vraiment de la haine entre
les communautés que je trouve que la
réaction
depuis depuis vendredi c'est vrai que ça
me dit voilà il ya une réaction où on
est tous unis on était tous les uns avec
les autres avec pour pour voilà pour
faire face à cette à ce drame
et depuis le début de la semaine je
trouve qu'à une dérive et je trouve que
j'entends des choses sur des plateaux
j'entendais je vois des choses sur les
réseaux sociaux
des appels à la haine qui sont assez
inquiétant mais pas trop rêver sur un
général d'aj en étant si je me permette
pas entre communautés n'ont pas d'autres
communautés communauté
les dérives lorsque ce qu'ils ont lieu
elles sont plutôt un caractère politique
c'est ça c'est dramatique c'est que
certains de que donne le sentiment de se
saisir d'un gramme nationale qui nous a
tous touchés au coeur c'est ça pour
essayer effectivement de prospérer sur d
idéologie nauséabonde à il a raison il
ya des gens du mouvement national dont
on sentait bien que ça leur faisait un
peu plaisir parce qu'en france
quelque chose leur donnera le g110
général de vinifier chef d'état major
qui dit oui
il étudia voir une guerre une guerre
civile mais tu étais d'un taux canapé tu
te dis mais c'est pas possible
discours comme ça un amalgame moyens on
amalgame entre l'islamisme et l'islam
vous savez la frontière elle est très
très mal ce entre islam et islamisme
comtesse que l'individu devient et
sionistes pour qu'il faut peut-être
connaître un peu de théologie un peu de
ce solo j'ai un peu anthropologie pour
pouvoir quand est ce qu un individu
passe du théologique à l'idéologique
donc il faut connaître la théologie en
vérité pour moi l'islamisme c'est un
recyclage d'un théologie médiévale qui
ne s'arrête plus à notre époque
l'islamisme n'a pas inventé une nouvelle
doctrine l'essayer de recycler par
théologie de politiques anciennes
ceux qui connaissent un peu les
classiques ils savent que c'est un
mauvais renvoi cyclage d'ailleurs parce
que la modernité de l'islam ou la
laisser au moyen-âge il y avait toujours
cette cette théologie spéculative
discursive où il a toujours l'argument
est le contre argument il y avait une
effervescence intellectuelle au moyen
âge chez les musulmans qu'on ne trouve
pas aujourd'hui parce que l'islam est
une religion qui devenu civilisation
sous l'effet de l'histoire et avec
l'effondrement de cette civilisation
c'est la religion qui qui est en train
de payer le prix parce qu'on n'arrive
pas à extraire la religion de cet
effondrement de la civilisation c'est ce
que j'ai fait un peu modestement de
travail et de sauver l'esprit de l'islam
de l'effondrement de civilisationnel
dont on voit les débris actuellement
l'islamisme c'est une fragments fradin à
fragmentation qui part dans tous les
sens
a pas de corpus doctrinal lisible il n'y
a pas de lisibilité du corpus doctrinal
c'est un islam is peut-être
d'opportunisme qui est saisie des
opportunités c'est presque ça un
réalisme inquiétant c'est un réalisme
inquiétant dès qu'il ya une opportunité
christophe gans être plus simplement
pour la droite pour les téléspectateurs
quand on met isma quelque chose c'est
qu'on est dans la politique c'est de la
mystique est passé en politique de la
marche quand environ 10 me pour pour le
communisme le fascisme le nazisme par le
haut des cuisses mais ça veut dire qu'il
ya une perversion de quelque chose que
moi j'adore qu'est la religion même si
je ne suis athée j'adore les religions
intellectuellement mais dès qu'on met un
isthme ça veut dire quelle idéologie
derrière or il ya quelque chose qu'on
n'avait pas prévu cyril il fallait
surtout pas qu'un jour une idéologie se
cogne et s'immisce et se mélangent avec
un une religion pourquoi parce que le
communisme est mort parce que les
communistes y en a plus il l'idéologie
morte le nazisme le fascisme c'est mort
de sa belle mort parce qu'on a vu les
résultats mais une religion par
définition ça ne meurt jamais or quand
une idéologie se greffe sur quelque
chose qui a toujours existé
on se demande quand est ce qu'on va pas
à s'en défaire